how did you end up being with beer for
the remix my manager linked me up with
her Rory should I worry
um and she was super cool she was like
she wanted to get on the song I think
she was actually at my Pomona show
[__] like four years ago or something
when I first came out she's been
following me on Instagram we've been
following each other so it was only your
time it was only right it was like a
no-brainer yeah
is that something she sends in are you
in the studio with her no I sent it to
her fire you and cash could work on that
originally together nah I had that song
I think I had that song for like two
years or something is it hard to get
like a [__] it the freak a leak sample
cleared so that's why we never really
try to put it out I made that song two
two and a half years ago and then
they're like yeah it's gonna be a
headache with the sample they're like
going and they don't have a hook they're
like we don't know if it's gonna like I
don't know if we want to [__] go
through it is it worth the headache if
they're yeah if it's not gonna be a
single right yeah yeah